it's the Mexican town where it's
Christmas every day lauawa hidden in the
country's Southwestern mountains
everyone else might be just getting
ready for the holiday season now but
here they've been at it all year
churning out 35 million Christmas spars
from January to
December the pride of T puawa is our
spheres they're a piece of our heart and
our understanding from the glass blowers
to the painters all of us put a part of
ourselves in them Town's people say
they're special because they're handmade
from the final licks of paint and
glitter to their beginning where Master
glass blower alustin who's been working
at it for more than 30 years Puffs out
fresh shapes like so many here this is
everything to
him it's really important to me and my
family it puts food on the table it
means that my children can study
Christmas ornaments resurrected the town
from a tragedy a huge landslide that
engulfed it and put an end to its gold
mining industry in the 30s it was lost
till migrant Hakim Munoz came back from
Chicago with some new knowhow how to
make Christmas tree bubles he quickly
set up his business and the rest is
local history this is his son Jose Lu in
the museum dedicated to his
parents when my dad returned from
Chicago he told my mom what he had
learned and they started the process of
glass blowing Christmas spares since
then flapo how ornaments have decorated
the Vatican and the White House about
60% of the Spheres in trapu Hawa are
exported now so it's not just Christmas
Central in Mexico it's an international
seasonal Powerhouse still looking around
the town a question remains sometimes
don't you'll get a bit tired of
Christmas there's no tiredness because
every year we're waiting for it excited
because we know we're going to give joy
to the homes in Mexico it's a good PR
answer but there's truth there too for a
town that saved itself through
Christmas John Homan alzer trapu
Hawa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer